three American citizens were released
today after being held prisoner in North
Korea for as long as two years yeah but
when they found out Donald Trump is the
president they immediately fled back to
Korea meaning that the other way it's
true today three American hostages
detained in North Korea have been set
free it's very good news yeah yeah
Melania yeah
Melania Trump asked hey if you're free
and hostages can I go too
president Trump said his summit with Kim
jong-un will not I repeat not take place
at the DMZ yeah Trump said forget about
it everyone knows the lines of the DMZ
are too long I'm not going I'm not going
thank you that one was really stupid I
was backstage I'm like I'm really doing
that guys were like I've been around a
while we like you it's okay
Best Buy big news Best Buy has
redesigned their logo in order to make
it more modern
yeah Best Buy is CEO said with this new
logo we're gonna sell a lot of VCRs you
know we have a good crowd when I just
said Best Buy has a new logo and the
crowd went it's the most [ __ ]
premise for breaking news yeah that
means some people stood up and went whoa
I gotta check that out
sure for cancer Wow big logo news this
is a crazy story an American Airlines
employee berated a young mom for
carrying a breast pump carrying a breast
pump yeah although it's still better
than the time the same mom was on Spirit
Airlines and she was asked to feed
everyone in coach
[Applause]
there's a great one last week legendary
rapper dr. Dre lost a court battle with
a gynecologist who's also named dr. Dre
a gynecologist yeah and adding to the
confusion of the gynecologist refers to
his patients as [ __ ] and hoes get on
the table [ __ ]
[Applause]
you